[Music]
welcome everybody to another great
episode of the careful boys we have with
us today mr chris sosa and walter holm
we got double today now we got some real
comedians in here thank god i know you
guys know each other from doing stand up
or not no no it's first time we met yeah
first time so you guys both have been
lying about doing stand up there
that's awesome
i'm at the live factory
i just stand up at home
well i have to do the last factory
how long have you been doing standup
i've been doing set up now for
seven to eight years
and you guys haven't crossed paths i
mean maybe maybe the show on the same
lineup but used to host chocolate sundae
i didn't host i was on it oh you're on
yeah
regular chocolate sundaes nice yeah yeah
yeah but you're not very chocolatey
though
it may have been
one of their first like yellow regulars
that's tight i may have been you're more
like butterscotch yeah a little bit now
yeah cause summer uh
i can't i can't say for a fact i can't
say for a fact i am one of the first but
like i i tell people i'm one of the
first i don't know if that's true but
you probably are you're og man could be
like one of the first and you're saying
that i believe it i trust it yeah it
sounds real cause i look old and
everything verifying right now i was
really young starting to look old you
only look old no when i started if you
called chocolate sundaes it took six
months to get your thing but now i heard
it's like four years yeah it's a long
time
four years three to four yo i i've been
on i've been on the waiting list with
the same thing but it was like mine was
a year but yeah it took that long for me
to like actually and that and that's
just to do the um what is it uh first
impressions first impressions so you get
first impressions which is before the
show they have two first impressions and
you get up there and do three minutes
and then the crowd and the producer the
promoter of the show is like
lonnie she'll she'll decide like if you
make it to the graduate spot and you got
to wait four years well now that that
list is long yeah it's gotten to yeah at
least three for sure yeah that's what
they got going on but it's cool i mean
it it makes you like work for it by the
time you get to that that's fine you
should you should do your thing even a
freaking bachelor's yeah right even the
graduate spot you still have to wait for
the graduates part so that's that's a
lie
so so you guys been in stand-up for like
quite some time right um i've been
noticing
a ton of new talent just popping up on
my instagram and i was just like is this
is it is there more stand-ups like now
coming out
then when you guys started and stuff and
like yeah is there like hell or more
stand up there's definitely a huge wave
that that is coming out uh for sure with
like a bunch of comedians and the way
the format has been because a lot of
comedians now are posting their jokes or
crowd work with the with the captions
you know showing that because
we kind of figured out like there's a
there's there's there's content there
there's piece of content that we could
actually as comedians promote our you
know our stand-up so people will go like
oh dope like yeah because some comedians
i'm maybe
it's different for you but you don't
want to want to post your set online you
know it kind of takes away from the the
the surprise of the jokes or you know
you can unfortunately run the risk of
like comic stealing jokes and stuff like
that but uh you get accused of oh man
it's the same thing on youtube that he
does on stage yeah yeah everyone
everyone watches like the tonight show
and like kimmel and they think oh they
have new jokes every day so you should
have new jokes every day well i'm sorry
i don't have a staff of 20 millionaire
writers to write me jokes all right guys
we'll do it then we'll sorry we'll do it
we'll hop on staff we'll be your right
request
so in this day and age would you say you
think like social media
um
if posting your your previously done
jokes do you think that helps your set
and then people go oh tell me that one
joke or do you think it ruins the shine
of that joke when you first release it
okay so in my career there's only been i
think like one or two times where i've
heard people like the crowd was like hey
do that one bit and it was it was mark
curry and i the story that i heard was
that he had he's from oakland he had
gone back to oakland this is after
hanging with mr cooper and all that and
he had a whole set dude get a whole set
and they go the people started shouting
hey do that one bit blah blah blah blah
and then do that one because you know
black people just shout stuff out yeah
you got the other extreme
you get lucky if they laugh you know
so it's a definitely a different thing
so they're shouting stuff out so
apparently mark couldn't do his set at
all
he just did requests all night he's a
he's a clean comic too right he's not
really clean but he's dude he is a beast
on stage dude he's great man that's been
i haven't heard that name of soul
if i were to um like request a bit
one of my favorite bits is actually by
uh kevin hart the one where he goes oh
i'mma give you what you want you know
the more he talks about
just let me reach in my dad yeah he's
getting robbed
he has his gun stored in his [ __ ]
dryer and he's like behind the toilet oh
i'm gonna give you what you want
i'll give you which one yeah
and then they add the audio in the back
which is super cool too it's a dope
effect
but what are you saying like what was
the the punch it was always the uh i
think the punch reveal it's him laughing
at himself yeah because he has such a
good time you know that he can like
because he's like i think that whole bit
i think um heightens like three times so
it's about a robber that comes in and he
goes now in this day and age is like
crazy so you gotta hide your guns all
over the place especially if you're
balling or whatever and then he has two
i think dobermans but they're [ __ ]
they don't do anything yeah so now on
the rubber the robber comes in like he
like he hides in different places but
then to like i think distract them he
tells them like i'm gonna give you what
you want and then he pulls out like the
gun but then seeing him laugh and then
him thinking about where the next place
is gonna be like he knows where he's
gonna go and he's like he's like
laughing at himself at the very last
like uh punch he'll go i got one more
and he's like crying laughing he's like
i'm gonna give you what you want
and you can't even get it out yeah
that's tight that's time i heard they do
that a lot now like um because people
that go to shows already know the set
they listen to their podcast so it's
like an inside thing right so when they
go they're just like do that one bit do
that one bit and then like i forgot if
it was uh tom segura or someone was like
half of their shows is just doing bits
that people like
that's dope right yeah isn't that a
[ __ ] dream though i mean that because
because when i mean thinking about it
right now i'm like uh would i want to do
that like what is that something would
be cool and i don't i mean thinking
about thinking like uh it would be cool
i just the only thing is that like we
know we all know where it's gonna go the
punches that's the most exciting part
when i when we're taking you in the
story and you guys have no clue that i'm
about to hit you with this so i like the
surprise yeah yeah yeah but when but i
if i could think about like what those
audience members are probably doing it's
like if you go to your favorite concert
like like your your band right fan
service you gotta play the hero stairway
you gotta do it yeah yeah you can't go
to led zeppelin concert without
listening to stairway you know i was
like why if people knew your [ __ ] so
much they were saying i'm with you
that's the boy
but i think people people i think
incorrectly equate
comedians and singers
because like singers you can go like i
always say america's got talent singers
have it the easiest because they suggest
they even highly suggest you don't do
original work like cover someone else's
song but a comment goes up they don't
tell the comment hey cover someone
else's word
you'll be good
and then so people come to the shows and
they talk to their friends
while you're on stage because they think
it's like a singer yeah like when a
singer is singing you can talk to your
friend it's no big deal won't distract
that per person but for a comic it
distracts us when you're talking to your
friend because hey what do you want to
do later
i didn't think about that
i didn't think about seeing people's
personal like little shits oh dude big
it's getting louder now it's getting
louder is it because there's a new crowd
that's coming in that don't understand
stand-up and then they're just like or
people are just more entertaining
etiquette i think it's both i think
there's new people and it's also hey i
can do what i want now like i'm entitled
you know what i'm more important than
this person i know no one came to see me
but i'm more important this person on
stage so i'm gonna be like yo hey when
we go out later what do you want to do
do you want to do shots or cocktails and
don't have these and make conversations
all the standards
on stage exactly heckling videos are
becoming famous yeah like andrew shows
like like his his crowd work was really
a lot of like had a big uh a a reason of
why like he popped off his is watching
his like clap back his clap backs and
stuff so now people kind of want to yeah
you know roast it back you know what i'm
saying it's like it's one of those
things where the heckling's even crazier
now yeah my opinion i think so too yeah
i think people are out there going yeah
that's me he's talking [ __ ] exactly
exactly
people also incorrectly assume all
stand-up comics do crowd work
and that's not the case either and even
the ones that do it 95
are written beforehand but the audience
believes oh he's just being off the top
of his head no it's like oh if there's
an asian guy right here i'm going to
make fun of this yeah and then oh dude
he's so on point like it's off the top
of his head no it's written down don
rickles who's the most one of the most
famous
everything was handwritten wow he would
have the host seat like said a jewish
person here said a fat person there so
all his movements were based on where
everyone was sitting wow so it was
constructed
yeah most comics don't
have the like because you have to be
wired a certain way to like hear
anything and then react like in a funny
way like a faith healer
the crutches
you know
yeah i feel like you want to be a jewish
guy right here
[Laughter]
jewish guy in this area
is there a fat man on the side
is there a fat man you can visually you
can visually see
stupid yeah it's it's it's definitely
like yeah because i think when crowds
come to comedy clubs they assume comics
are a certain way and then when they
don't get that they're like oh this guy
sucks but it's like no it's certain like
certain comics do one-liners they don't
do stories some comics do stories and
they don't do one-liners you can't say
oh this comic sucks so they don't do
one-liners you know and so i think
people that go to comedy clubs when you
guys go be open
like you're there to laugh that's the
main thing don't forget that yeah don't
forget that
oh man i totally forgot do you think
people in the past
the comedy audience understood like just
what was what they were going for more i
think so because they went frequently
now also like they would go like it's
like going to the movies every week yeah
it's like a regular thing now you got
people that just come for the first time
or second time they're like oh i got
this like i know what to do i've had
people comment
on the jokes as the comics are doing
jokes and it's like what are you what
are you doing the hell yeah like like
like they're [ __ ] commenting like
it's youtube yeah like
they'll make like comments it's not like
they may say oh that was a good joke or
a bad joke it's like let's say you're
talking about laundry like oh yeah like
yeah i do laundry too
they
it's like it's like they're in
conversation with you you know they're
like in it someone get that guy mike he
does laundry too
i have a question about uh comedians
online i feel like because everything is
such a uh like a sports highlight of
someone's set only the best [ __ ] will go
online for certain comedians have you
ever seen a comedian online that you're
like oh this guy's funny and then you
saw his whole set and you were like dude
had like one good joke oh
say their name go ahead
camera and tell them who it is
[Laughter]
wait
oh uh yeah i mean for sure i mean i
don't know i think i think in general
with social media right we want to post
our best bangers bangers right like you
know what i mean like you're not you're
not posting you're lifting them
[Laughter]
doesn't even do it i'm like get caught
every time bro
because it does the it's the prep it's
the pet the whole [ __ ] thing and i'm
like winning out of muscle
he shows his [ __ ] ass
or if it's on the bench his back arch is
so crazy i'm like oh he's about to
[ __ ] go in and the video ends the
[ __ ]
he falls over
oh i feel where i'll go with that oh you
want to post your bangers uh but yeah
you wanna you also listen for like the
the heaviest laugh you're like oh this
is this is going to be the 15 second
that i that i that i post whatever but
yeah you definitely have to follow up
with like you know you got to make sure
your set's going to be nice you know you
know i mean like can't go out like that
you know but it seems like nowadays most
people just post like their crowd work
though like as their clips it does seem
like something that can be a little bit
more disposable than actual material
right right it feels more candid too
yeah yeah that's what gets people in
because i feel like all these people
that are hopping on this trend that's
what they tend to do like that whole
stavros that falls popping up everything
everywhere and it's just him [ __ ] on
different people different hecklers that
like you guys brought up that just want
to be a part of the conversation and
they just start talking to the comedian
it shows it shows a little more
authenticity you know what i mean like
of uh of uh or he's naturally funny you
know oh he oh he naturally has it he's
yeah he's he's thinking this on point
technically right he's just coming up
with it on the fly
people like to think they're unique so
like like let's say a white guy that's
like pudgy sits down he thinks no one
else is white and no one else is pudgy
dude jokes about me being white the only
white guy yeah but the comic has already
made jokes about a white pudgy guy a
thousand times a thousand times so when
the guy sits down everyone thinks oh
yeah this guy's like crazy he's funny
no one ever came into this club that's
white and his pudgy no one ever did
you know and so and so the the thing
that sucks about you know when you only
do crowd work what sucks is the audience
could turn on you too because they'll be
like oh this guy's not funny enough to
write material
uh so it's like you can't win one way or
the other
yeah yeah it's a balance it's a balance
you can't go full on crowd work because
then it's like because then especially
if they're just dedicating their whole
show to just this these two people in
the front row then everybody else in the
audience is kind of going like okay well
what about what about us then what about
me you know yeah yeah there's a cup like
ian bagg is known for his crowd work
his whole set is crowd work
i don't even think i've ever seen him do
regular material it's just all crowded
he comes and starts roasting yeah he
just starts talking to everybody and
like that's one way to do it you know
posts for like 10 minutes
that's his hosting
[Laughter]
imagine you buy his album you don't know
anything that he's talking about
yeah that's that's what
it looks like
what is this guy he's talking to yeah
it's like radio show you're like wait no
i don't see the guy i don't know those
that are based heavily on the like the
local city that they're performing in
you know you know right
oh that barbecue spot down the street
everyone's like going crazy though
they're going like
yeah oh yeah the people and what's funny
is when you travel people tap when town
will say oh if you do a joke about this
they'll love it because it's specific to
local time like yeah but if i take time
to write this joke um i could only use
it here
like i'm not gonna you know i'm not
gonna do that you know
i mean i know some comics do like a
quick couple like one-liners here and
there to drop about the local knowledge
two three minutes of it yeah the
audience gets hyped the obvious but
when you listen to it you're like what i
i don't i don't know that street or like
i don't know
i don't have like jokes where there's
just like a blank and you can put
whatever town or thank you you don't
feel your name your city yeah it's like
the southwest commercial welcome you
know thank you san francisco like we're
in l.a yeah it's like one of those
things [ __ ]
i don't think i've ever have you ever
had a moment where you like messed up
the city that it's out loud saying like
you know orlando your mind i'm on a
crowd
i've done that hosting i've done it to
comics names oh because on purpose no
yeah no no i wish i wish i was on
purpose
one of the worst ones for me
because like this guy's name is cisco
this comic's name is cisco and this is
like this is where the worst and best
ones so um when it's a new word or i
don't know the comic um like chris is
easy like okay i'll remember like when
you come out says chris but like
for cisco i know the word but i don't
know i didn't know the name and the
guy's name you know associated to him i
go on stage and i'm doing my set
and he's the first comment and bring him
up and in my mind i know it's that
there's a c and a c and an o
but i've neglected the i s
okay in my mind so i'm just like okay
cool i mean everyone walk on the stage
coco
and then he's on the side and he goes
it's cisco and i go and for me like when
i make a mistake i'll start over
like i'll own the mistake but that's
funny and i start over people do you
like walk back and then walk back out
well no what happened was it's like
you should do it was like oh you know
hey and then so i was like hey everyone
you know what and i put you know listed
his credit again and i was like everyone
put your hands together for cisco and i
brought him back on right now like dude
i'm so sorry man and then the security
guard he go he's locked his guys
he goes hey you know what though you
were confident with it i believed it was
everyone believed his name
everybody make some noise get on your
feet
get your hands together you see them all
over the country and you're in your head
you're like what's his name what's his
name
you're building it up yeah
oh there's a seat oh
looking at your phone
he's performed here
do you guys know the comic ron pearson
no he's a juggler amazing juggler so
like towards the end of his set he has a
whole set of just juggling and he does
comedy while he's juggling wow now i
hate now i hate that i don't
i know because the thing you're like
yeah he's a crazy juggler like that's
why we don't know
i'm sorry i'm sorry about that you guys
are juggling actually he has time he'll
balance the stool on his chin he goes he
goes around a lot with george wallace
yeah i'll just pick a city on the at the
airport and they'll go you didn't say it
was royal perform like oh gee george
wallace yeah yeah yeah
that's so crazy so ron pearson that name
sounds awfully similar to ron perlman
who if you don't know rom the actor
guy from hellboy yeah he narrates the
ufc like embedded things oh he does oh
that's a deep cut yeah so at the time
sons of anarchy was big
so i'm you know i'm thinking you're like
oh ron all i have is on my mind is ron
paul
but then as soon as i say ron i'm about
to say perlman ron perr i'm like his
name's not ron palmer he's not wrong
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing so i was like no joe
i went
you know put your hands together for ron
and i'm like what's his name what's his
name
the whole time
oh you got it
and then ron comes out and he goes wait
what was that i go dude for a split
second i thought your name was ron
perlman but i know it's not
and he starts dying
[Laughter]
you just turn into a dubstep dj
dude
[Music]
you